like it should be 50 50 custody like off
the bat
i don't know why women are like even if
the man doesn't want 50 50
the child would have to live with the
founder 50. well i mean if he doesn't
want to be in the
life i guess not no he wants let's say
but he doesn't want the child staying
like four days he wants like one day i
think off the back it's just
i think off the bat they should start
with 50 50 custody and they can work it
out between them right like the
government should say you both have to
yeah like 50. that makes sense yeah
because i don't know why women are just
assumed to be better parents when
they're more likely to abuse a child
they're more violent towards their
children how are they true 100 percent
i've seen it
yeah what have you seen
um so
you can go supermarkets you can hear
them i'm shouting at the child
um i had um
i had a couple on these hours like that
and it's like i've even got some friends
that were like that and i know a couple
of times i've been like
why are you shining like that so much
sometimes obviously it's not as much
prevalent as it is now back in the day
it was a lot of beating as well
but
the way i grew up all my friends me the
dad is the one you know shouting obitino
you know the mom is not the one but
that's that's the parent difference
in comparison but could it could it be
that it's because the moms are around
the kids more yes because you know when
you are around a child more they
frustrate you more yeah like if you're
just coming like if you're even not in
the picture
or uh if you are but like you work a
long hours and you only see your
children for like a little short time if
the mom is with them like pretty much 24
7 they're gonna drive her crazy i think
i'm gonna disagree on that one i think
women are just more emotional true yes
like like you know women are more likely
to wage war
to wage war
like percentage-wise like i know more
men have because more men have been in
power but women are actually more likely
to do it when they're in power
what's wait wage wool like star war
like go to find like yeah just i think
like i just think we get pissed off
i've seen a lot of women trying to fight
men thinking what are you doing so yeah
that's another bad one because even in
my household i like i lived with both
parents and
if i compared the two
my mom did way more than my dad did
like he knew ways to con not say control
us but to keep us obedient
that did beaten
as in the early early stages yes but
even then
he didn't really need to be as much we
weren't that bad as children but at the
same time
it was like if he needed to raise his
voice it was
situational
where my mom was shot constantly that
was like a mechanism
my mom used to hit me with a spoon
a wooden spoon was it yeah
i deserved it
don't get me wrong for like uh single
mothers it's not it's not easy bringing
up a child or kids on your own it's
tough you know i applaud them for what
they do but when you start getting angry
and you know
screaming at your kid and there's veins
coming down your neck you know that's
you just um that's just way too much
too much anger for a child that doesn't
understand what you do the only thing
they can get from that is trauma
but there's you know in all the
situations ninety percent of women are
look at the the parent to the child
there's only ten percent of full-time
single dads that look after the child as
the main parent just 10 percent so i
feel like
that doesn't government prioritizing
women to have customers
yeah it could be but i feel like men
don't know how it is like to have a
child almost 24 7.
that's because
i feel like it must
single fathers raise better children
exactly than single mothers
when they have been given the chance
they've done a better job exactly
yeah i just think women like we get
frustrated like when there's a problem
yeah because when we do something yeah
we just get frustrated and like cry or
get mad
yeah and i do it too like like even even
and i kind of noticed the differences in
like the genders doing like solving
problems because even with like my
business like i'll be doing stuff and
i'll just be like get mad at something
and my brothers will be like okay why
don't you try this this this
specifically like they're just more
logical so do you think a man would do a
better job raising a girl than than a
woman
yeah
yeah right what about the feminine side
um would she be more masculine than
probably um i would say like she's
probably
she'd probably be a tomboy
it might be hard to find a man my mum
was raised by my granddad so my mum was
had has four siblings
she's the youngest
my gran my mom my nan ran off
different
life
then my granddad raised worked has his
own business and raised four kids
my mum it was a single mom
i'm not
blown away i'm blaming trumpet because
she's the best mom raised my brother me
and my sister strong woman was the
breadwinner was everything the decorator
everything was she's shouting a lot all
the time but she did it because we were
bad kids
she's like she was a young mum she had
my brother at 15 me at 17.
but that she got i feel like she got
that strongness from my grandad because
he was a very strict
working man
did everything he played both roles
so i just think
it differs whereas she was raised by a
man i was raised by a woman so i feel
like i've got both why i i actually like
this idea that like men raise children
better i would believe that because
they're more logic why more men
is it because of the government because
i feel like a lot of men wouldn't want
100 custody of the child oh no they will
uh they want their freedom to no no i
think most men want to be in their kids
lives
i can't remember what the stat is off
the top of my head but one of the most
likely times that a guy is going to
commit suicide is when it's like
post-divorce because often times she'll
take care of the divorce yeah what about
men who not like in marriage-wise yeah
but let's say men who who've been in a
relationship there's no marriage they
just had a child with someone would they
actually 100 because because i feel like
they're very happy with 50 or less
um are you talking
about men when there's no marriage it's
just with a woman that they don't want
to be seen i don't i don't know but like
in my experience most men want to be
with their children even even if it's in
a shitty situation for the most hundred
percent unless they're like one of those
guys that are just you know
everybody but that's right that's the
majority but i don't think most men are
gonna want a hundred percent because if
you're in
if you're alive and in the child's life
why would he want a hundred percent he'd
rather do 50 50.
because at the end of the day even the
stats say that then a better father's
there's a certain element to a child
that a man can't give
that's what a woman needs to be around
so being 100 to your child is not as
fully beneficial as it would be having
both so
say me for example as a man even though
i may want 50 i'm not going to 100
because there's certain areas i can't
give you i can't tell you what it's like
to be a woman in this world do nothing
like a lot of men are happy to see the
child twice a week and they don't want
50 50. yeah that's probably because they
have to rather than because they want
some guys and they they they're happy
with their like yeah two days a week
every other week yeah it's not like it's
banned everything's one big one
it's a month
was that a father that was actually
heavily invested in that woman before
they had a child no if that was a if
that was an unplanned pregnancy yeah it
makes sense it they i i think both of
them were unplanned yes yeah so if he
was heavily invested then i'm pretty
sure two days might not be enough
in his mind but you might have to settle
for it no i i know someone then asking
for someone or
i know two other people once basically
in the
all right fair enough
but i'm just saying i personally do know
of people and me myself also i was
raised like that every other weekend so
there's people out here that just
they just don't want more responsibility
with their children yeah i don't see men
really wanting unless there was marriage
or something but wanting 50 50 i think
they're happy for the saturday sunday or
just saturday
i don't know i i think most men want
have
i think most men want their kids to turn
out better
and most men want to be a part of that
in general
um i i think sometimes maybe there are
cases where women kind of trap a man and
like the men are kind of resentful
because like they don't they didn't want
this kid to begin with and she kind of
knew what she was doing
yeah would you say that's true yeah
yeah no
yeah i agree
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible